the four sir it is a real divorce shop a
shop you should be the doctor
[Music]
you
Oh what if I only cool any pretty well
[Applause]
Zod police aquarium on Avianca
veeravasaram
we stand absolutely united with the
French people against terrorism the
terrifying moment terrorists strike in
the heart of Paris soon Bisou Bisou get
down get down says one resident watching
from a rooftop let's not let up don't
move a friend calls out as one man takes
it closer look at the shooting below
perfect in full combat gear these aren't
amateurs but disciplined well-trained
killers with assault weapons it's
mid-morning the gunman's target is a
satirical magazine then the men turn
their attention to a police officer
whose image we've obscured he's injured
but they go on to kill him in cold blood
leaving the man's lifeless body on the
pavement they then head to a getaway car
but not before gloating about the attack
which is shocked and appalled around the
world goons of my life Jessica I think
what we know so far is that a car with
three masked men arrived that Ruane bear
number 10
inside charlie Abdo they used automatic
weapons
kalashnikov's and killed whoever was
inside so we think 11 to 12 deaths and
that's including those who died inside
as well as two of our colleagues outside
yeah but there are others who are
wounded five seriously some critically
time will tell if there are more victims
but we luxury cool they dump their
vehicle to take another so you can
imagine all our colleagues are after
them so we are using video technology to
try and track them we're searching
through all videos and CCTV and we're
hoping to find them quickly Oh booth or
firstly those men are our most wanted so
that stays the priority they're armed
and extremely dangerous and things will
certainly evolve
behind the scenes the gunman left behind
a sickening and bloody scene forcing a
staff member at gunpoint to enter a key
code they walked into a boardroom as an
editorial meeting was being held calling
out individuals names they shot their
targets at point-blank range
apparently shouting god is great they
wanted dead journalists and cartoonists
determinate a video shot on the
planchette when the shooting was over
there were already a lot of police
around lots of police showed up but
there was nothing we could have done I
recollect I saw calm men I would even
say determined men because I immediately
confused them for police officers or
professionals I told myself
they must be surveillance police
something bad must have happened the
Apophis unit were the police you it'll
mid-tier sorry Valkyrie on Anton I was
on my balcony and I heard a loud noise
which sounded like firecrackers and then
I heard it again it lasted for about ten
minutes then I saw policemen running and
I saw that one was injured
so Jordi Venuti
good amongst those massacred Stefan
Shibani a editor of the weekly
publication Charlie Hebdo known as sharp
he'd received threats before but refused
to tone down the magazine it strongly
defended cartoons featuring the Prophet
Mohammed once saying I'd prefer to die
standing than live on my knees we are in
a weird situation in France Islam is the
second religion in the country in terms
of practitioners and in fact nobody
knows anything about Mohammed nobody
knows anything about this religion it is
a religion that scares people because
every time we talk about it it is when
we talk about bomb attacks done by an
extreme minority also murdered the
magazine's lead cartoonist Jean Camus
and George will insky an 80 year old
satirist who'd been drawing cartoons
since the 1960s famous names in France
known for ridiculing those in power
[Music]
with the gunman on the run the injured
poured out of the building
a normal day's work with deadlines to
meet and articles to be written had
turned into a morning of slaughter and
terror an actor exceptional but it was
an exceptionally barbaric attack
committed here in Paris against the
newspaper which also means against
freedom of speech and against
journalists move abroad the security
level in Paris has been raised and we
are looking for the perpetrators of this
crime today France has undergone a shock
and has suffered a terrorist attack the
attack happened not far from the very
center of the French capital less than a
kilometer away from the plaster la
Bastille the Charlie Hebdo offices are
on this street rue nickel are a pair
they carried out their assault on the
building's second floor following their
attack they made their getaway but as
this photo shows they were seemingly
confronted by police around the corner
in alley there there also appears to
have been another shootout
just yards away on Boulevard Richard
Lenoir a main thoroughfare that runs
through much of Paris where this police
cars windscreen was repeatedly shot at
it was near here the injured policeman
was shot dead it's thought they then
drove towards the northeast of the city
and abandoned their vehicle here before
hijacking a second car and turning the
driver out into the road a short time
later the original getaway car was
discovered what clues will it deliver as
to who would carry out such a crime and
why I know that this house and this
country stands United with the French
people in our opposition to all forms of
terrorism and we stand squarely for free
speech and democracy and these people
never be able to take us off those
values see cowardly horses once again
very very but within minutes there was
an explosion of outrage and sympathy on
Twitter and other social media sites
amongst those commenting other
journalists Piers Morgan writing
horrendous story from Paris comedian
David Walliams posted executing unarmed
cartoonists can never be the will of any
God and thousands of people have now
posted this picture just suis Charlie I
am Charlie supporting the freedom of
speech and in response to the gunman
claiming they had killed Charlie Hebdo
the United States Embassy in France even
added the comment to its official
Twitter page in his lop the editor of
Britain's satirical magazine Private Eye
commented that the dead journalists paid
a very heavy price for exercising their
comic Liberty very little seems funny
today he said cartoonists are fighting
back with their pens they are uniting to
stand up for freedom of expression
[Music]
France is on its highest state of alert
there are now three thousand extra
police on the streets Security's been
tightened at several newspapers in
France and around the world Charlie
Hebdo has been repeatedly threatened for
its caricatures of the Prophet Muhammad
and other controversial sketches its
offices were firebombed in 2011 and the
magazine's been taken to court
unsuccessfully for insulting Islam it's
been a bloody few weeks for France the
country has suffered a number of attacks
a van drove into a Christmas market
injuring shoppers and in Dijon another
driver plowed into pedestrians hurting a
dozen people he was shouting god is
great but this attack is different calm
organized killers who drive an
inconspicuous vehicle and knew when to
strike they can handle with ease an
ak-47 firing whilst running they had
done their gruesome homework speaking
fluent French with no accent they
apparently claimed to be affiliated to
al-qaeda that terror organization and
the Islamic state group of both
repeatedly threatened to attack France a
father
vuvuzela natales echelon email daily in
order to facilitate the apprehension of
the three criminals who committed these
barbarous acts with a smallest possible
delay all the resources of the interior
and justice ministries have been
mobilized in order that the
investigation gets underway quickly as
the day drew to a close there were
demonstrations and vigils
in Paris and around the world and the
French president addressed the nation
Yacouba Fiat or jewel Milla force idea
at the Chaos honker today France has
been attacked at it's very hard in Paris
in the building of a paper and this
violent attack killed 12 people and
wounded some more Missy preacher je vous
ET avec une or today in your name I will
like to express our gratefulness to
those people who are wounded to all
those who have been killed by this
cowardly assassination today they are
our heroes or up show the shooting in
central Paris lasted just minutes the
repercussions are only just beginning
and the gunman who killed with such ease
and precision are carrying out the rest
of their plan
for now escaping capture and justice